Marvel Cinematic Universe fans have
since discovered plans were underway
behind the scenes to give Thor and Loki
yet another different sibling a brother
who might be more familiar to comic book
readers and lovers of Norse mythology
that's right balder the brave was almost
introduced to the MCU to further
complicate Thor's family tree former
Marvel Studios head of visual
development Charlie Wen sent MCU fans
into a frenzy back in August 2018 with a
single Instagram post when posted
concept art for Thor the Dark World that
revealed his take on adapting longtime
Thor Comics character balder to the big
screen while the character's inclusion
in the film was eventually scuttled it's
exciting to imagine how the MCU might
have been different had balder survived
pre-production ball Bears really kind of
the true heir to the throne if you
really want to put it that way and so
like there's a lot of things about that
character that can be really key to the
story